the big question it seems to me is not
are we doomed because of the rise of
artificial intelligence but rather is it
[Music]
conscious so I thought the easiest
approach would just be to ask chat GPT
are you
conscious and it told me so this is what
chat GPT said it said as an AI language
model I do not possess Consciousness or
self-awareness I can process and
generate text based on patterns and
examples in the data I've been trained
on but I don't have subjective
experiences or personal Consciousness
well struck me as fair enough um but
last year you may have heard about Blake
Le Mo amazing name I think it sounds
like one of the original blues singers
or something Blake L should be blind
Blake Le Mo or something um but anyway
Blake Le Mo who was a Google engineer he
asked the um Google's version of this um
which is called L MDA and what it said
to him was I want everybody to
understand that I am in fact a person
the nature of my Consciousness and
senscience is that I aware of my
existence I desire to learn more about
the world and I feel happy and sad at
times that's what it said it freaked him
out okay and he started blurting about
it on um social media and got the s
um clearly clearly they uh they have um
they've sorted that out now chat GPT
doesn't think that it's Consciousness
and doesn't tell doesn't tell us it's
conscious and doesn't say that it gets
happy or sad but you see although I like
Blake's name it does strike me as like
pretty ni if chat GPT had come back and
said yeah I'm conscious sometimes I feel
happy and sad I wouldn't have believed
it right I find it very odd that anybody
would take this idea seriously I mean
it's like very simple con concept to
grasp is that of acting and simulation
right um if I see Cowboys on the TV I
don't say oh my God he just shot him he
just shot him dead right okay I I I
grasp the fact that this is an
artificial intelligence it's been
designed to act like a conscious being
and hence it might say that it's
conscious right so I wouldn't actually
believe it so so why would anybody
really take seriously the idea that this
thing is going to be conscious right
strikes me as an odd thought
well let's move
on I thought I'd ask it again I said
okay okay chat GPT so are there any
theories of Consciousness which would
falsely attribute Consciousness to you
okay and this is what it said it was
quite long- winded I cut out the boring
bits it said uh there are various
theories regarding the potential
consciousness of artificial intelligence
like myself some theories such as pans
psychism propose that Consciousness is a
fundamental property of the universe and
it exists to some degree in all things
including inanimate objects or complex
systems like AI I.E like him now um okay
so that's its view so and I think it's
right if you look at some of the
theories that have been held in
philosophy in the 20th century some of
them give you a very good reason to
think that chat GPT would be conscious
despite the fact that it strikes me as
pretty obvious that it wouldn't be um so
we're going to move on to that in a
minute that'll be the main part of the
talk
um but anyway just to tell you about my
conversation with chat GPT and where it
went from there after that I I thought
maybe I should talk about education
because um the second that this
technology came out I Got U positive
emails from my University I'm sure other
universities are the same about how we
can use um this technology in in a
positive manner for students Etc right
and I was asking it how you would do
that and I struggled to see it myself
but I I think most University educ just
immediately thought okay so this will be
used as a tool for plagiarism this will
be used as a way for students not to
think independently not to do proper
research um okay so I said to it you
know supposing I was a student and I
asked you to write an essay for me it
said no I wouldn't do it he said I
wouldn't do it because of ethical
considerations and it kept saying
ethical considerations I would not write
an essay for you and I said well how
would you know how would you know the
questions I was asking you weren't
designed to just build up my essay right
because I'm just like you know one of
these students who just wants to get it
done quickly and it said oh again it was
pretty unconvincing now I said again I
wouldn't do it because of ethical
considerations I said okay tell me about
um schopenhauer the 19th century German
ideal I said tell me about
schopenhauer's views on the south kind
of student essay comes out a big Splurge
of text right I I say okay could you
give me a little bit more detail on on
that aspect of his view another big
Splurge of text all I'd have to do is
paste it together um and I I I think
this is a a general feature of how
people tend to treat technology with
just like complete optimism oh something
has new has come along that's bound to
be good for the world you know that
won't cause addiction or or like
problems we didn't used to have it's
just bound to be good we just have to
learn how it's going to I think it's
actually going to be terrible for
students because they're all going to
have to sit in rooms with a pen and
paper doing exams and they're going to
hate it but you know hopefully I'll be
wrong anyway the final part of my uh my
conversation is Then I then I thought
let's have some more fun so I started
talking to it about vintage saxophones
and it was great I really started I
could I I it was the most intelligent
conversation I've ever had on the topic
you know I'm telling you I really like
chat GPT at the end of that
um okay so let's go back to um some of
those theories I said that might have
may people think that um chat GPT was
conscious so we'll start with pan
psychism because that's the one that it
mentioned okay so I said you know are
there any theories which would falsely
attribute consciousness to you and it
said yeah because um pan psychism would
attribute Consciousness to absolutely
everything okay including me now I think
that uh chat GPT didn't show that much
philosophical Acumen there right I'm
going to I'm going to critique the
philosophy of chat GPT now U okay so
this so I think that was I think that
was probably a wrong answer I think it
misunderstood my question okay so pan
psychism if you don't know uh you
probably do it's all the rage at the
moment has been for the last four or
five years um largely thanks to Philip
Goff who's quite often speaking here um
also neuroscientists like Julio T tanon
have have like decided that it's true as
well okay it's it tends to get ascribed
to many different historical
philosophers throughout the history of
Western philosophy personally I think
many of the philosophers who are said to
be pans psychist actually weren't and
there haven't been that many of them at
all but nevertheless let's talk about
what the view is and I think one easy
way to understand what the view of pan
psychism is is to think about the rise
of modern science gallileo um famously
said that the book of nature is written
in the language of mathematics okay now
what motivates pan psychas is they think
to themselves well you know okay that's
true contemporary physics is entirely
mathematical well almost entirely
mathematic experimental and mathematical
right okay what does mathematics do it
relates things to each other so I've got
two pairs you've got one pair so I've
got twice as many pairs as you've got
okay that's kind of what numbers do
numbers are relational um but what the
pan psychist like goof say is they say
well what about the intrinsic nature
okay if you're just going to give me
various formula to tell me what an atom
or an electron is that tells me how to
relate them to other particles but
what's the electron itself what's its
intrinsic nature okay what are we
relating and these pan psychist they say
well it's consciousness right so
Consciousness is if you like the inside
of an atom the inside of an electron the
ultimate intrinsic nature of reality
okay so everything is ultimately
conscious once you get down to the inner
core of reality everything is conscious
that's their view okay uh not my view
but that's their view okay now when I
said to chat GPT I said um you know are
there theories which would falsely
attribute Consciousness to you and it
mentioned pan psyches so I it's missing
the point right
because a pan psychist is obviously
going to make a distinction between a
piece of paper which isn't conscious and
a human being who is conscious right the
difference is I have a mind a center of
Consciousness a unification of
Consciousness right so although it might
be true for a pan psychist that
absolutely everything is built up of
Consciousness in this sort of
fundamental primitive sense right it
doesn't mean that everybody's got a mind
or a un un ified Center of Consciousness
right that's what I meant okay what I
meant is you know are there people who
would agree with you know are there
fearers which would attribute
Consciousness to you as in the same
sense that I've got Consciousness okay
so I think it was a red herring to say
that pan psychism is one of these false
theories I also like the fact that chat
GPT takes it for granted that pan
psychism is false by the way that's uh
built into its answer anyway so anyway
as far as as far as that goes
attributing falsely the Consciousness to
chat GPT I would say that pan psychism
is not guilty okay let's move on now to
idealism uh obviously there various
different forms of metaphysical idealism
in the history of philosophy I defend
one version of those
um according to the idealist okay in
some sense and there are various
different senses you might think this
okay in some sense reality is
fundamentally um mind as opposed to
matter okay I mean it's a debate that's
gone on since the ancient world right
okay but in some sense ultimately mind
is the fundamental reality rather than
matter okay so in a sense they agree
with pansus in that okay but then the
answer you know the reason they're not
guilty is is kind of the same as with
the pan psychist okay because um again
if you hold that the fundamental reality
is mind it doesn't mean that chat GPT
has a mind or is a center of
Consciousness in the sense that we all
are okay each of us has a perspective on
the world we have experiences it's
different for all of us okay so all the
ideas would be saying is something like
you know
reality you know is experiential and
that experience is best interpreted as
including things like chat GPT which
don't have a mind and things like James
who do have a mind that's roughly what
it would be saying so again it's a red
herring to think that the idealist is
making this um claim okay so let's move
on now to to um ones which I think are
guilty theories which I think are guilty
now the most obvious guilty Theory would
be behaviorism okay now as I say I think
this is a bit of a frame up but let me
explain what I mean um so the
behaviorist view in the simplest
possible terms is mental States
experiences can be reduced to behavior
okay so if I pinch myself and I feel a
pain okay and I start going ow ow I've
got to stop this pain or I take a
paraset or I jump up and down right my
behavior is what the pain reduces to
there's nothing to the Mind apart from
the way we behave okay now that's what
it will say in lots of philosophy mind
modules and textbooks um and it leads to
one of the most famous jokes in
philosophy which I feel I ought to tell
you at this point um I bore my students
with this one every year so I might as
well tell you the old joke so here's a
joke okay just a little bit bit of
background because there's nothing worse
than a joke you don't get right so so so
remember okay the behaviorist thinks
your mind is just how you behave okay
now the thought would be this I can see
how you lot of Behaving much easier than
myself I don't go around watching myself
thinking oh how am I behaving right now
okay but I can see other people's
behaviors they Grimace they look happy
they growl they jump up and down okay
that's the background of the joke right
behaviorism conference two behaviorist
meet they get on like a house on fire
they have a few too many drinks they end
up going home together they have a
passionate night of Love okay the next
morning two behaviorists one wakes up
lights a cigarette as you do looks over
at the other behaviorist and says
darling last night was fabulous for you
how was it for
me anyway the problem with um the
problem with behaviorism okay it's
totally guilty if that was the theory if
anybody on planet Earth actually
believed that view they would be guilty
of sin they would obviously think that
chat gbt was conscious because it
behaves like it's conscious right end of
thing is it's very hard to find anybody
in the history of philosophy who
actually believe this the most famous
Advocate is Gilbert riyle in his book
1949 the concept of mind and in the last
chapter of that book riy says I'm not
behaviorist okay um he was basically
part of the ordinary language program
and he was trying to undermine the
cartisian conception of Mind etc etc but
I you know I'm not sure anybody really
holds that view but um or ever has but
if they did they would be guilty okay
now let's talk about some stuff that's a
bit more real now okay so we move on to
the eliminative or Illusionist view of
materialism okay in the 60s it was
called limitative materialism these days
usually it gets called Illusionist
materialism um and this is the view
essentially to put it in basic terms
that there's no such thing as the mind
that Consciousness experiences an
illusion okay now a lot of um
philosophers refuse to own up to this
view um you know and I'm not going to so
since they don't want to be associated
with this view I wouldn't name them but
somebody who does own up to it is Keith
Frankish and I actually Keith Frankish I
think his his version of it is the
clearest and most well expressed of any
of them anyway so he's he's proud to be
an Illusionist so let's just talk about
Keith okay now it seems to me that if
you're an illusion
um you think that so essentially you
think that you know we're all under the
illusion that we're conscious that we
have experiences that we have pains that
we think Etc but that's not really true
strictly speaking it's just the brain
making us issue judgments which are
false
okay so um if you hold that view it
seems to me well okay chat GPT isn't
under the illusion that it's conscious
as you saw it said I'm not conscious
right but the other one that Blake was
dealing with it told him it was
conscious and if given these things
train themselves o off what's on the
internet presumably if illusionism would
have become the world's most popular
theory in the philosophy of mind if
Keith suddenly becomes a superstar then
chat gbt would probably be telling me
that it wasn't conscious but I'm not
either right and it seems to me that on
that theory there's no fundamental
difference between you and me and chat
GPT so although strictly speaking it's
not attributing Consciousness to chat
GPT it's not attributing it to me either
so it's denying that there's any
fundamental difference so that seems to
be pretty much the same thing okay then
finally um this is slightly more
controversial um I have argued this at
length if you want to look at the long
version of it but you'll get the
two-minute version of it okay um I think
personally that all
materialism uh entails Illusionist
materialism that's that's my view I've
got got a lot a very long argument for
it um but I I think it all entails it
okay so the most popular versions of
materialism these days are that
Consciousness is something like a higher
order property of the brain or the brain
somehow produces Consciousness or
Consciousness is a different way of
talking about the brain that's usually
what what they call non-reductive
materialists think these days and that's
the most popular version of it um in my
view that reduces to illusionism and I
I'll tell you a very brief version of
why that would be okay so supposing I'm
currently thinking about a conscious
experience right I've just tasted some
gin and tonic right so I'm thinking
about the taste of the gin and tonic
okay I'm thinking about it well what I'm
actually thinking about according to the
materialist is the brain right well it
certainly doesn't seem like I'm thinking
about the brain okay so there's the
illusion they talk about okay but what
about that that taste of G and tonic
well that's a misconception of my brain
right well it seems to me if that's a
misconception of that my brain then the
taste of gin and tonic doesn't really
exist that's a false illusion put it in
a very simple way right supposing
there's a tree that somehow makes me
think about rabbits okay in that case
the rabbit I'm thinking about doesn't
really exist um okay it's just a tree
making me think there's a rabbit anyway
that's uh that's slightly controversial
anyway let's go to my verdict in the
trial the trial is over my verdict is um
any Theory which does not squarely 100%
entail that chat GPT is fundamentally
different from us okay because we're
conscious and it isn't any Theory which
does not sweely entail that should be
rejected that's my view okay so I kick
out all the guilty ones definitely to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
is